est-ce que c'est pas le moment pour une
petite vidéo serait de la ba oui allez
on y va tout de suite ça fait longtemps
qu'on a pas fait de ce raid mais
pourquoi ça fait longtemps parce qu'à
pas de ce raid incroyable ces derniers
temps on va pas se mentir
aujourd'hui ça parle pas d'une histoire
paranormal d'un lieu hanté de chez pas
quoi ça parle d'une [ __ ] d' enquêtes
criminelles qu'un tweet hausse à mener
seul lourds ou pas à son passé
aujourd'hui il s'agit d'un thread
espagnol décidément les espagnols mecs
hyper chaud dans ce raid c'est un budget
il s'éclipse trop bien et comme à chaque
fois qui distrait d'espagnol dit
traduction par lauren merci lorraine
j'adore ces petits running gag de
rehausser leur aide alors je déteste
dans leur évite vous allez voir c'est
très intéressant je vais juste vous dire
les trois premiers tweets du thread et
vous allez être à fond dans ce
incroyable tout commence quand sur
twitter un utilisateur du nom de pelote
tweet s'adresse à la police en disant
qu'il vient de résoudre un crime à
travers twitter et qui demande qu ils
prennent ça très au sérieux il apporte
une petite précision en précisant que le
mec au milieu de la photo est décédé
attention spoil
il s'appelle georges wod petit spoil et
que la ferme a été fermée comme un
suicide
alors qu'il s'agit d'un meurtre et qui
peut le prouver deuxième précision le
tueur est sur la photo et ça y est vous
êtes à fond dans le nord des shows allez
c'est parti on y va sur une enquête
commence par une simple visite sur le
twitter de georges surprise sur cette
page twitter peu de tweets et aucune
photo est dans sa bio twitter petites
infos importantes comme george à grâce
aux initiales plan tweet il a réussi à
trouver les événements racontés dans un
article d'un journal de la région
apparemment georges se serait suicidé
par défenestration alors il est revenu
sur la page twitter de georges et la
tchéquie un peu tous les tweets qui s'y
trouve est à la recherche d'un 10 de
quelque chose sur sa vie qui aurait pu
le menace suicide et il est tombé sur un
truc intéressant qui dit la chose
suivante parfois en scène pour rien
parfois on se blesse pour rien
soul et urbaines sentimentale georges
tweet avant dans son enquête il se dit
[ __ ] mais georges était peut-être en
plein chagrin d'amour et peut-être que
ça a quelque chose à voir avec les deux
autres mecs qui sont sur l'image d'après
la légende de la photo elle aurait été
prise quelques heures avant l'événement
donc le suicide de georges dans une
discothèque dans le centre de barcelone
il est donc possible que l'élément
déclencheur et eu lieu à ce moment là
dans cette boîte de nuit avec ces deux
personnes sur la photo en plus de george
george semblait en plus traverser une
période difficile de sa vie à d'autres
tweets qui indique qu'il n'était pas
bien notamment un juste avant d'aller
dans cette fameuse boîte de nuit vers 3
heures du matin et qui dit aucun désir
je vais essayer à nouveau un dernier
effort et signé quoi ou juste blood
sweat ensuite vu que sur l'image ya
quelqu'un qui était identifiée qu'il
s'agit du garçon en rouge à gauche dans
la photo il a donc pu se rendre sur son
compte twitter pour avoir plus d'infos
sur ces gens et sur peut-être ce qui
s'est passé lors de cette soirée
mauvaise surprise il n'y a pas de tweet
sur son compte twitter mais bonne
nouvelle quand même il avait rempli sa
description de page twitter il ya une
info c'est qu'ils les graphismes et le
gros truc louche surtout c'est que
felipe et georges ne suivent pas sur
twitter plan tout le dit lui même
comment peut-on paraître autant amis sur
une photo et pourtant ne pas du tout
semblé l'être sur les réseaux sociaux il
va donc se mettre à penser que peut-être
y at-il entre ces trois personnes un
triangle amoureux c'est possible il ya
de la jalousie de l'amour mais aussi de
beaucoup de sentiments négatifs qui
peuvent pousser un suicide
warm heart à l'emploi tweet tourne un
peu en rond j'ai diplo tweets au moins
10 du foot pelé vu de la vidéo c'est
insupportable et à force de regarder la
photo qu'il a mis en fond d'écran sur
son ordinateur tels moyens faire blocage
sur cette histoire il remarque qu' un
truc bizarre avec le tatouage de georges
alors à première vue y a rien d'anormal
c'est juste un tatouage de keke où il a
marqué liberté or dans une petit peu
dégueulasse
pardon certains ont même temps je suis
autant mais c'est vrai merde quoi
marquer frieden en gros sur son bras ça
va deux minutes mais là où il ya quelque
chose de bizarre c'est que quand on
regarde le tee shirt de felipe qui est
donc à gauche de l'image on remarque
facilement que les lettres sont à
l'envers parce qu'ils sont face à un
miroir et donc sa route ont l'image à
l'horizontale un peu comme ça voilà
exactement comme ça mais du coup
pourquoi le tatouage lui n'est pas à
l'envers c'est celle où il devrait être
comme ça sur la photo il devrait pas
être droite du tout alors il a tatoué
freedom à l'envers exprès pour qu'on
puisse lire le mot uniquement quand il
est devant un miroir bizarre mais quitte
à faire un tatouage de keke autant
ajouter un truc original à part dont je
suis pas objectif quand on va sur le
profil twitter de georges on peut
trouver une photo de son tatouage et on
peut clairement voir que le freedom
n'est pas du tout marquée à l'envers une
seule conclusion possible la photo a été
retouchée mais on n'avait pas petite
info la sueur a le grade
istres si quelqu'un a retouché la photo
c'est forcément lui il est graphiste il
serait donc totalement capable de
photoshopée une photo pour y ajouter un
tatouage et autres informations
importantes c'est pas felipe qui a posté
la photo sur twitter mais c'est luis le
mec de droite sur la photo ce qui veut
dire que si la photo a été retouchée
avant d'être publiés sur twitter luis et
felipe son complice le tweet mais direct
à imaginer des scénarios un peu macabre
des scénarios dans lequel georges se
seraient effectués par luiz ou felipe et
felipe luis s'arrange pour publier une
photo fake 2e en boîte avec georges pour
faire comme s'ils étaient très amis et
ce jusqu'à la veille du suicide de
georges il y a des gens dont on n'a pas
parlé depuis le début de ce thread c'est
les gens qu'il ya dans le fond sur la
photo il était à cette soirée ce jour là
aussi pourrait peut-être donner plus
d'infos comme par exemple confirmé le
fait que la personne au milieu de la
photo n'est pas georges et que c'est bel
et bien quelqu'un d'autre qu'on a
photoshopée pour y ajouter le visage et
le tatouage de georges claude tweet a
été très malin la seule info qu'on peut
avoir sur le ces deux personnes c'est
sur la personne de droite on voit un
morceau de son tee shirt et en
augmentant très fort la luminosité de
l'image on peut voir un petit motif à
paraître qui correspond à celui d'un tee
shirt adidas savez le 3 plus simple il
va donc fouillé les comptes twitter de
nos trois protagonistes dans l'espoir de
trouver une autre photo sur laquelle
lloris mec qu'on connaîtrait grâce à son
tissu adidas en espérant qu'ils soient
identifiés sur la photo et qu'on puisse
donc le contacter grâce à son compte
twitter et bingo luis a aimé le tweet
d'un gars qui posté juste une photo de
lui et son t-shirt et ben ya clairement
le logo adidas dessus donc c'est lui le
[ __ ] de maître sur la photo et on à
son compte twitter c'est magnifique
notre enquêteur malgré lui décide de le
contacter pour obtenir des informations
salut désolé de te déranger on se
connaît pas mais j'ai une question sur
une connaissance de georges clairement
un gros mytho et pourquoi pas il mène
son enquête il a raison le garçon qui
s'est donné la mort samedi matin je
connaissais pas énormément de fait
j'habite à madrid mais nous nous sommes
déjà vu quelques fois j'essaie de
récolter des infos car je tourne un peu
en rond sur ce qui s'est passé à putte
un ouais je comprends je suis très
touchée aussi on se connaissait pas
c'est bien que ça c'était seulement un
ami dhabi mais je suis quand même choqué
personne ne s'attendait à ça ce qui
m'intrigue le plus c'est pourquoi at il
commis une décision pareille juste après
avoir pris cette photo avec luis et
felipe thonidés ce qui a pu se passer
entre eux comme je te le dis je les
connais pas si bien que ça mais chez que
luis et georges ont été ensemble pendant
un temps au mais ça fait genre plus d'un
an qu'ils sont séparés en fait je crois
que louis c'est avec felipe maintenant
mais ils doivent quand même être potes
pour se prendre en photo comme ça non tu
te souviens de ce moment ou pas tu étais
présent ce soir là c'est bien toi le
garçon fond de la photo
[ __ ] j'avais jamais vu cette photo
mais c'est bien moi je savais pas non
plus que jorge était là dans la boîte
mais en même temps j'ai peu de souvenirs
j'avais un peu bu j'étais fatigué à
cette heure là je me souviens plus de
grand chose mais je suis sûr que kapoor
attendait un peu plus c'est le mec qui
est à côté de moi il a beaucoup moins vu
que moi donc il subit forcément de plus
de trucs il a pas twitter mais je te
laisse son ulti peut joindre sur what's
app attend georges était donc en couple
avec luis mais maintenant luiz est en
couple avec felipe
moi si j'étais george aurait un peul
sommes à en juger par les tweets de
georges aucun désir je vais essayer à
nouveau on en conclut qu'il sait pas
vraiment remis de sa rupture avec luis
et qu'il a donc logiquement le sommes
contre felipe le nouveau mec de luis
alors là on commence à accumuler
beaucoup d'infos dont claude tweet il
est mignon et nous met un petit schéma
qui résume tout ce qu'on sait pour le
moment le mec de gauche c'est felipe
donc probablement celui qui a retouché
la photo le mec du milieu c'est georges
mais c'est du bullshit on sait que c'est
pas georges et que son usage a été
modifiée le mec de droite c'est luiz
lemaître cap twitter la photo derrière
eux se trouve à gauche carles et à
droite crime
le mec à qui on vient de parler et donc
la seule piste qui nous restent
actuellement bas c'est de parler à cars
et lui demander s'il a vu georges ou pas
et blood footsie perd pas de temps et
l'eau 18e déranger on se connaît pas
c'est queen qui m'a donné tous nuls je
suis une connaissance de georges deux
garçons qui est décédé samedi je
connaissais pas très bien mais on s'est
vus plusieurs fois j'ai besoin d'avoir
des infos sur ce qui s'est passé c'est
pas toi la personne au fond sur cette
photo si c'est moi je me souviens bien
de ce moment mais je n'étais pas là elle
sort d'où cette photo [ __ ] c'est
dingue
elle vient du twitter de luis
sérieusement je sais pas c'est quoi ce
bordel mais je peux jurer que georges
n'était pas là bouchard je n'ai donc bel
et bien jamais allé à cette [ __ ] de
soirée où était georges et pourquoi
felipe et louise ont voulu faire croire
qu'il était là en boîte avec eux là
notre sherlock holmes maidi n'est ce pas
une galère un peu et tourne en rond mais
il ya un truc qui peut nous donner des
infos et qu'on n'a pas relevé sur la
photo attention essayer de deviner
[Musique]
la montre de felipe mon pote la photo
ils ont été prises dans un miroir il
suffit de la retourner et ensuite on
obtient l'heure exacte à laquelle la
photo a été prise cette nuit là et c'est
plutôt clair à peu près cinq heures 55
les articles sur georges disent qu'il
est décédé à 5h30 comment aurait-il pu
être en boîte à 5h55 ça confirme donc
définitivement le fait que la personne
au milieu de cette photo n'est pas
george mais quelqu'un d'autre à qui on a
ajouté un tatouage sur le bras et à qui
on a ajouté le visage de george mais
alors à qui appartient ce corps [ __ ]
un truc qui pourrait nous aider à savoir
si le gars du milieu est complice c est
ce qu il a essayé de s'habiller comme
georges le jour de sa mort bingo dans
l'article qui parle du décès de georges
il est bel et bien spécifié qu'il
portait un polo noir comme le mec de la
faute au milieu ils ont donc vraiment
voulu faire genre que c'était georges
sur la photo et là vous êtes en train
d'errer dans vos écrans vous vous dites
mais c'est qui le mec au milieu sec et
alors on va recontacter cars pour lui
demander plus d'infos sur ce mec du
milieu
salut désolé de te déranger encore une
fois tu te souviens du mec à qui ils ont
pris la photo
pas vraiment je vais pas trop prêter
d'attention mais j'ai vu passer 2 3 fois
c'est un mec normal du même âge que les
deux autres et je n'ai pas vu de la
soirée jusqu'à ce moment je me souviens
d'une chose il avait les yeux bleus et
les cheveux bruns et je crois qu'il
était étranger merci il ya une grosse
interrogation dans l'histoire c'est
pourquoi ont-ils eu besoin de faire
semblant que george est allé en boîte de
nuit l'une des raisons valables ça
aurait été de mettre des bâtons dans les
roues aux policiers qu'ils essaient de
reconstruire le parcours de georges les
dernières heures avant sa mort dans le
sens où ils vont croire qu'il est allé
en boîte ils vont demander à plein de
gens de la boîte s'ils ont vu etc ou
s'il a fait des trucs bizarres tous les
gens de la boîte bondir banon on l'a
même pas vu c'est on danse et on a la
tête ailleurs et donc ça les mène à rien
et la pelote oui tu as vraiment des
compétences d'enquêteurs qui dépasse
complètement
cet inspecteur squeeze soyons francs
pour lui l'explication la plus logique
c'est que georges se serait rendu à la
maison du meurtrier mais on a retrouvé
georges défenestré au pied de chez lui
donc c'est à dire qu'ensuite le
meurtrier serait allé avec georges chez
georges après avoir buté georges
meurtrier serait dit [ __ ] peut-être
quelqu'un m'a vu ou entendu je suis dans
la merde alors il aurait appelé louis
c'est felipe pour leur demander de
l'aide
il aurait donc monté ce petit délire de
photos pour faire croire que georges
était en boîte luis et felipe aurait un
alibi de ouf puisqu'il était vraiment à
la boîte de nuit au moment où georges
est mort donc voilà si fier une photo
pour rester que dalle puisque leur alibi
en béton il était vraiment pas avec
george congé mort mais pourquoi luis et
felipe aurait eu intérêt à coopérer avec
ce mec dont on connaît pas n'ont qu'à
buts et georges est le point le plus
important pourquoi george va dans la
maison du meurtrier au lieu d'aller en
boîte rejoindre louise essaie de le
récupérer
bah c'est évident parce que le meurtrier
était le nouveau mec de l'ouest
notre ami plan tweet est donc allé
fouiller dans leurs abonnés sur leur
compte twitter et il a cherché un mec
qui correspond aux caractéristiques que
nous a donné notre ami et bingo il a
trouvé qu'un seul utilisateur qui avait
un nom étranger et c'est william et jose
la photo de profil bas rupts bingo il a
bien les yeux bleus et les cheveux bruns
et la petite étincelle dans le cerveau
notre sherlock espagnol et comprend tout
luis felipe williams forment un tandem
sentimental c'est à dire que felipe et
william sont amoureux de luis et que
luis est amoureux de felipe et william
george se fait plaquer par luiz et luiz
n'a pas un nouveau mec mais de nouveau
mec t'as pitcho georges serait donc allé
toquer chez williams cette nuit là pour
lui dire de rester loin de luis la
jalousie on connaît bien tous mais bon
de là à ce que william répondre par le
meurtre c'est un peu violent donc
peut-être que george aurait menacé avec
quelque chose la théorie de pelote tweet
c'est que george aurait en sa possession
des photos de son passé sexuel avec luis
et l'aurait menacée williams de les
faire tourner si jamais ils n'arrêtaient
pas de voir luis qui aurait à cfoot eu
la frousse et le sommes à williams pour
être une grosse merde et tu es georges
et c'est comme ça que l'histoire prend
fin braquant pelote widowmaker sherlock
dommage que tout ça soit faut arrêter je
sais que vous avez le sommet vous avec
la plupart des threads que j'ai fait
c'est sur des trucs fake à 100% mais
comme j'ai déjà dit on s'en fout que je
sois faye quand ça nous a bien diverti
que c'est bien écrit et là je dis bravo
parce que claude tweetie la chine et
mais en plus petit succès déverrouiller
pour lui il ya le compte twitter de la
police espagnole le vrai comptes
certifiés qui a répondu à son ce raid en
disant vos recherches ont confirmé le
rapport de nos investigations si vous
êtes victime de ces extorsions la police
vous aidera ne cédez pas au chantage
c'est magnifique modesto garcia et le
créateur de ce serait donc ces blogs
tweets et la crise on serait dans le cas
d'un concours pour le festival fait ryad
l île aux espagnols élevé de bonjour et
il a gagné le concours et on comprend
pourquoi ce serait des fous et en plus
c'est trop bien parce que ça parle d'un
sujet qui est beaucoup d'actualité qui
est là les changes de new le chantage
avec des photos sexuelle de souvent de
ses ex alors j'en profite aussi pour
dire un mot là dessus même si le roi des
rats fait une vidéo qui vous pouvez
aller voir et qui parle de ça et qui est
très intéressante et c'est horrible ne
cédez jamais au chantage de photos
sexuelle ou de vidéos sexuelles de
sextape ou je sais pas quoi il ya que
les gros gros immense fils de [ __ ] pour
faire ça et je le sais vous n'êtes pas
les fils de [ __ ] alors ne faites pas ça
c'est débile et si jamais quelqu'un vous
menace avec ça parlez-en à la police
fait quelque chose mais ne vous laissez
pas faire il faut surtout pas rester
dans le silence si vous avez des news de
votre copain de votre copine quand vous
vous séparez vous voulez supprimer
les partages est passé complètement
inadmissible de faire ça ça peut
vraiment détruire des vies de faire ça
alors ne le fait pas et encore une fois
si vous êtes victime de sa part les ans
police c'est important voilà h couteau
j'ai pu parler d'un sujet en plus dont
je voulais parler l'oeil et le thread
c'était l'occasion d'en parler génial ce
serait du début à la fin il s'était pas
aimé le thread si vous a plu si vous en
voulez d'autres des différents etc
ça faisait pourtant jura il est fou si
là il est fou je vous dis à bientôt je
ne vous dis pas ce que je vais faire en
passant cette porte mais il se peut que
ce soit du red dead redemption
[Musique]